so here's a mirror of sort it's curved
and in front of this mirror I put this
rectangular sheet with something drawn
on it and when you put it in front of
mirror and look inside a mirror you see
a cat you know with pointy ears and
sided protrusions that look like
whiskers and everything so I'm very
happy with this cat I'm proud of this
guy nice cat I will say that when I show
this to mathematician and Cisco
physicist colleagues some people like
this because they have good taste but
others say so well that's really sad I
hope that they didn't say so but for
those of us who would like to say so
here is the thing in front you have a
mirror indeed but that's what we call a
convex mirror so it's bulging out to
order in the back inside of the tube
there is a concave mirror which is
building away from us so now I'm going
to put another cat inside and look at
what happened and if you look from the
correct angle you see another cat inside
by the way some people might wonder how
many reflections are bouncing off before
it reaches eyes but in fact it's just
one reflection
it's circling on the back side and
they're coming out so you have a cat on
the inside now a slightly odd thing is
that cat on the inside looks very much
like the cat on the outside
although the cats on the outside is from
a convex mirror where is the cat from
the inside is from a concave mirror so
convex and concave I mean there are
opposite things and you might expect a
bit distortion in fact be the opposite
but they look very very similar so
that's quite interesting it's not much
of a hint but one thing that has to do
with this effect is the following this
arrow is pointing from left to right and
if you look at its image reflection in
the mirror in front the convex part it's
still pointing from left right but let's
look at it on the inside on the camara
it's pointing right to that so that's
quite interesting it reversed its
direction so it's a matter of where with
respect to focus you are placing the
arrow as I move the arrow inside or
equivalently
the mirror you see the arrow changing
its shape and somehow it sort of blurs
out and eventually at the end you come
to the point where you see really the
image next to the the original arrows so
you can do something like this with a
spherical mirror and little rectangular
sheets of paper when I first sort of
this you know I thought something like
this might be interesting to try the
major problem I said to us where do you
find a cylindrical mirror I mean if you
have a flat mirror you know slightly
bowing out the bulging in so that
changes the size of your image and so on
where you can find that in cosmetic
shops and so forth but where do you find
a cylindrical Mir a two black mirror and
I thought and so and finally I went to
the Stanford Shopping Center and the
found on these are cookie cutters it's a
cookie cutter you know values like a
cookie dough and then cultures so you
can buy one for $1 and with that you can
make a cut in the mirror catching a
cookie cutter that's
one not talk to the other by 90 degrees
and in this toy model you'll see exactly
what happens if I support those two
objects like this they stick together
because the stiff one is at the bottom